okay
um okay thank you for hanging out with
this one um
so i'd like to talk today about event
store and go
my name's ken faulkner um day job
c-sharp programmer mostly i wish it was
go um
but i use a lot of event store which can
be used for event sourcing
so i just like to go along the practical
side of using this similar
i have some microsoft swag as well but
um
i will give the code out at the end so
it'll be more of a case of
who can type the code out the quickest
we'll get
we'll get the four parts of the swag
so i'm not a person to talk about cqrs
or ddd
or aggregate routes there are far better
talks already out there
um google google that if you want a
really good presentation on
understanding that i am not the person
for that what i want to show
is purely using the event store product
which is used for event sourcing
um and the go language so if you're
after
i don't want to say theory but it's sort
of if you want the sort of the
event sourcing specifics of it hit hit
google or ndc's had plenty of talks as
well
now with relational databases i know
this isn't
strictly true um all the time but
relational databases
are really good for storing what now
looks like
so this is this these are all my tables
this is all my data
now but there are situations where you
might want to be able to sort of like
trace back from the beginning of time
well the beginning of your application
um or your service
up until now so it might be a case of
this sales event happened that sales
event happened
this happened that happened you might
need um sort of like
basically a a detailed history of
everything that's happened
as opposed to just purely now that's
where
um event sourcing or event store comes
in
so think of it like say as a stream of
immutable events
now apart from having the full history
there
one there there are two things that i
found very very useful with this
um if you're in an industry that
requires auditing
so you might be in finance you might be
in medical you could be just anywhere
with
some authority will come around and say
give me every event associated with like
not literally the universe but so
everything to do with
these sales events we need to see
everything we're going to order you
fortunately since a whole event store is
event event event event it's a case of
it's very easy to generate those and be
able to hand over hey
mr auditor here's the data you want go
away
um that's that's one benefit but to me
the single best benefit of this
is being able to replay all those events
from the beginning of time onwards
so initially the business might have
said
oh okay we're going to build
functionality a b and c
golf indoor developers okay so we go off
and do that we've used event store
as our sort of source of truth and then
6 12 18 months later they come back
as the business always does actually
we'd also
like functionality d i
would be really good if we had that to
begin with um so it's sort of it's using
the same set of data but they're doing a
different computation or maybe
maybe it's just a fix um but more often
than not i've found
hey we'd also like this i wish you told
us that before
now since we're able to since we've got
every single event that has happened
we're able to code up um this new piece
of functionality that takes all the
events
and there's your answer and so you can
actually just replay
every event and it is as if it existed
back then
so you run through the millions billions
tens if you're not busy um of events
and there you've got your answer and so
being able to just
add extra functionality as if it was
there from the beginning
that to me from a practical point of
view that has been one of the
real life savers being really good
so what i'd like to show you is just
the amount of code is tiny but how to
generate events
into event store and how to process the
events or how to read them
so code time
so oh now before i do
this okay cool so hopefully you're all
seeing command prompts at the moment
i just want to show you um how to start
up event store and
i've got nothing on my sleeve i have a
nice
empty directory here now when you run
event store now to install event store
just go to event store.com.org or
choco however you want when you run it
okay in this case i'm saying okay my
database is in current directory my logs
are in character
so i run that it goes off it starts
creating some base information and it's
now got the service running
so but look at that it's gone off and
created some stuff for me
now one nice thing it does as well is it
uh supplies a web interface let me just
reload this
come on
[Music]
there we go okay forget about all this
this is not what we're going to cover
what i want to have a look at is just
the stream of data
it's at the moment when i started up
that um
event store it created some users and
all that but it's got no data i haven't
added anything into it so i just want to
show you this interface we'll come back
to that in a second
so we're going to create a producer and
consumer
really basic stuff so i'm either going
to make the assumption that you no go
or the syntax is simple enough that
you'll get the idea
regardless of the language that you know
so first thing and this is really is
minimal code
i create an uh producer event store demo
structure
and i have a look up here i've got a
connection to eventual that's all that's
there there's
really not much to it then i call spam
again
which is just my producer it's just
gonna keep making stuff
now when i ran event store second ago in
the command line and i said it created a
user
one of the first things it does it
creates an admin user with a password
change it
to subtly remind you okay go off and
change this
uh we're running on localhost that
support and
default is just the name of the stream
that i'm going to use you can have as
many streams as you want
so it's not like you're intentionally
mixing up
sales events and windows events and
these events and that events you can
split them all up
however you see fit or you could dump
them all in if you like chaos you can
dump them all into the one stream
if that's what you like to do so let's
have a look at spam again
there are three parts for this this
these first two parts these are boring
um all it really is doing is taking my
parameters and
creating a connection string so it's
going to be tcp
username so admin change it local host
port
that's it so that's just creating the
connection string
that's using the connection string that
is really bog standard
um by the plane so i don't want to go
into that
and all of this is on my github account
i'll give you a link afterwards
now what we do we loop 10 million times
just for the
sake of this demo we generate a random
payload which is just
json it's just a string i add it
to a new event i'm giving it an id just
a good
and i append it to the string so it
really is generate json
wrap it in this class that eventually is
expecting
and attach it um generate random payload
just to show you
um i generate so i'm creating something
with a department and an amount
uh so i've got four random
um departments i'll just take one of
those and then an amount between zero
and a hundred
you generate the json dump it into event
store
so if i have a look at
so i'm just going to run that now okay
so i haven't bothered producing any
output there but if i go back here
i now have a default stream now click on
that
oh yeah actually one thing i should say
is at the end of that loop i sleep for a
second and then i'm just going for my 10
million
so at the moment it's just chugging
along
i've got a department of sales id1
amount 31.
they're just we're just getting all this
random random data
so i'm just going to leave that running
the generating events to me
is boring what i like to do is all
the events that we've got different
systems writing into adventure
what what um business value what new
piece of functionality can we get out of
it
out of this because it's amazing
sometimes what
data will get in there and then it's a
case of well we've actually got the data
produced
something tangibly useful for the
business anyway
consumer producer that's just running
let's look at the consumer
this is the more fun bit same sort of
stuff
i create a consumer event store demo
that's just got a few
important things here it's got a
connection same as the producer and it's
got a subscription
which is it's subscribing to the default
stream and every time
something happens there it'll call my
function but
admin change it localhost same port etc
etc
let's go back up to here this is a copy
and pasted the other bit of code so
create my connection string and use it
boring
this is the interesting part so now
we're going to subscribe
to the stream so the stream name is
default
now when we subscribe we can tell okay
where do we want to subscribe from where
do we want to start do we want to start
at event zero
which was written seven years ago and
it's got way too much data
or do we want to start somewhere else
now in this case i'm starting at event
zero for the purposes of the demo
practically what you're probably going
to do is
every time you process an event you're
going to okay yep we're processed we've
done this
you're going to write to a persistent
storage somewhere saying oh i got to
event
one million ah and so when the or if the
server restarts
or it crashes and it needs restart or
whatever
um next time it starts up it'll know oh
i've got up to a million i'm going to
continue on from 1 million and 1.
but in the case of what i'm saying
earlier where you
might create a new piece of
functionality and you really do want to
start from the beginning of time
this is where you say no we're going to
start from zero
once we do that so we're saying we're
going to start um we're going to read
the default string we're going to start
from zero
every time an event comes in we're going
to call a function called process event
very simple function and this one's
super complicated
we read the data we unmarshal it into a
sales event
now scroll up here sales then it just
maps what i had in the json so we've got
a department and an amount
uh we take that and we print it out
that's our super complex bit of
functionality
so if i run this since i've told it to
start from event zero
what you'll see is it'll quickly go
through everything really quick and then
it'll catch
up so it went through everything that
consumed a producer had already created
and now it's actually just sort of in
lockstep with
it it's consuming the stuff as soon as
the producer makes it
so that is some that is a very simple
thing to do now
just say the business comes along and
says actually no we just want totals of
the sales we don't care about those
other events that's
for another department we need to know
about the total sales
so what we can do and again this is just
trivial code but i just want to sort of
demonstrate the point of
okay if our department was sales id 0
1 let's go process a sales event
and here we just we're going to take a
running total of
the sales of it so the other ones
they're ignored at the moment we don't
care about that
so if i rerun this now you'll see that
okay again it'll rush through
all the events that were happening and
now it's actually caught up and now it's
just taking into
account paying attention to the sales
events
and being able to just sort of create
these again this is a trivial example
but being able to create the new pieces
of functionality
um that will go off and add business
value it is
i i love this product
um let me just okay
so generating events extremely easy
um very easy to add consumers later on
it is one of to me one of the biggest
strengths being able to do that
comparatively long resource requirements
so for my day job we've got a cluster of
three uh event store nodes so you've got
them
um we're sitting at like three to five
percent cpu on those things
um yet sometimes it's under sort of like
we're hammering it with lots of events
but still
it is it is very very good from a
resource point of view
but what i've shown you is the older
version of gm
of event store now the reason i haven't
shown you the newer version which came
out this year
is because all the client code is grpc
as opposed to just sort of standard tcp
or
comparatively raw tcp sockets the
go client or the official go client
isn't out yet
um i think it's supposed to be out soon
but uh i keep hearing very different
dates
there are the proto files there so you
can generate your own client if you
would like to
but personally i'm just going to wait
for the official client to come out that
way i've just
one less thing to maintain i don't have
to maintain the client and
my actual real code
um but yeah hopefully that will be out
um
soon so that's that's basically it all i
want to really emphasize is
try it out if you are into or want to
dip your toes into event sourcing um
it's great for some situations it's not
great for other situations if
if you want to try it out it is so easy
to just sort of like dip your tone in
the water
and then go
so uh if you want to try it on azure we
run all our stuff on azure so these are
the same links
as shown earlier if you're interested in
anything
microsoft devwise please join the
community newsletter
go to this link if you want the swag and
you will be asked a secret code which is
ken
f21 the first four people there now
you've all stopped listening i'm sure
and you're now just trying to click on
links
um first of all people to do it uh we'll
get the swag
uh this presentation and the code that
i'm
using is uh at my github so
kp faulkner ntc sydney2020
and i hope you have learned something
from me
um on to the next person
you